k
[Música]
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos sejam
muito bem-vindos a mais uma live de
respostas às perguntas dos apoiadores e
discussão de
artigos eu vou abrir aqui o documento
com as perguntas de vocês pra gente
poder começar aqui me de só um instante
e como vocês estão à medida que vocês
forem entrando por favor deem um alô
dizem digam né se o áudio está legal
at Ok pronto já achei a primeira
pergunta
aqui deixa eu dividir a tela com vocês
Prontinho obrigado pelo feedback Carlos
Obrigado Eliseu pelo feedback também
alir al não é aloir né desculpe
aloir Deixa eu tirar o monitor do
modo fic mais fácil de ler pronto aloir
mesmo em vista do grande número de casos
de influenza o doutor recomendaria tomar
a vacina eu realmente não recomendo
tá em situações normais poderia até
recomendar essa
vacinação a questão é que eu sempre fui
desconfiado essa vacina de influenza
primeiro ponto a respeito dela é que a
necessidade de todo ano vacinar porque o
vírus da gripe sofre muitas modificações
é uma mutação muito frequente isso já me
deixa um pouco preocupado com a
questão do impacto ao sistema imune de
dessa vacinação repetida todo ano
na minha experiência de consultória já
vi muita gente fazendo essa
vacina e pegando gripe do mesmo jeito
agora com a questão das vacinas de RNA
mensageiro que existe uma suspeita muito
grande que
exista eh a questão de estarem colocando
o RNA mensageiro em outras vacinas eu
diria que paraa maioria das pessoas eu
tomaria muito cuidado com essa
vacina mas eu vou dar a visão oficial
para vocês também tá essa é minha visão
pessoal mas a visão oficial é que seria
uma medida preventiva muito importante
recomendada porque o vírus da influenza
nesse grupo de pessoas idosas pode levar
a complicações graves como a questão aí
da pessoa desenvolver uma pneumonia
viral e que a vacina seria importante
para evitar essa questão
a vacina disponível atualmente ela
protege contra os principais vírus o
influenza a H1 N1 o influenza a H3 n2 e
o influenza B são as três cepas que tá
pegando certo então é é bem complicado
isso né porque se a gente fala qualquer
coisa contra a vacina a gente
considerado maluco né mas a minha visão
pessoal sobre isso is é que é muito mais
importante se manter essa vitamina D de
dado em bons níveis tomar vitamina C
usar o própolis usar quercetina quando
indicado cuidado do seu zinco cuidado do
seu magnésio do Complexo B Eu acho que
isso vai dar uma uma proteção muito
maior cuidar para não ter uma
hiperglicemia não ter uma resistência
insulínica isso vai dar uma produção
muito maior do que ficar tomando essa
vacina que todo ano tem que repetir
porque ela não tem uma
eficiência entende tá então vocês
escolham a versão que vocês sentam no
coração de vocês que é a
versão melhor a oficial ou a minha visão
pessoal
Ok boa noite Estela também que entrou
aqui teve aqui hoje no consultório
Estela Mares querida Estela Mares
próxima
pergunta quais são os benefícios de usar
prasterone inre no lugar do dha Hum quem
que perguntou isso deixa eu ver se eu
tenho o nome da pessoa foi a ru Elita
não ru Elita foi da vacina foi Eliane
Eliane você está acompanhando ao vivo
Eliane achei curiosa essa essa pergunta
né
usar prasterona com naut Rexona no lugar
do Deia na verdade a prasterona e Deia é
a mesma coisa tá Eliane mas eu não sei
de onde que você tirou essa Associação
Talvez para tratar doença autoimune
porque tem alguns protocolos de usar o
dha em altas doses para algumas doenças
autoimunes como é o caso da Artrite
reumatoide Então existe esses estudos de
usar dha em altas doses 100 200 mg a
doença autoimune então talvez esteja
falando né nesse contexto como você não
explicou Qual é o contexto que você tá
querendo dizer eu tô imaginando que seja
esse mas a ideia seria você modular o
sistema imune através do uso do do Deia
junto com a naxa axona tem um efeito de
bloqueador piode mas em doses baixas ele
vai aumentar a atividade de
opiode vai ter um efeito neuroprotetor
também então é interessante uso muito
naut exona aqui no consultório por conta
de doença autoimune aí se você tiver uma
doença que já foi estudado o uso de dhia
em altas doses também pode estar
associando os os dois juntos por ex
atrit eemat só que aí em mulheres essa
dose de 100 a 200 mg de dha vai dar com
certeza virilização vai aumentar a
testosterona pode engrossar a voz pode
dar acne pode dar
hipertrofia clitoriana uma série de de
situações tá tem que pesar muito bem se
for uma doença autoimune muito
debilitante aí vale a pena correr esse
risco a prasterona que é o dha ela tem
efeitos neuroprotetores
neuromoduladores ajuda na densidade de
óssea ajuda na aumentar massa muscular
assim quando eu uso a prasterona aqui no
consultório só para melhorar a qualidade
de vida dos pacientes melhorar a massa
óssea muscular medular o sistema imune
sem necessariamente tratar uma doença
autoimune a dose que eu uso é 10 mg para
mulheres geralmente 20 MG para homem
agora pra doença autoimune você teria
que estar utilizando 100 a 200 mg por
dia
OK não sei se eu respondi a tua pergunta
do jeito que você queria tá se você
tiver ao vivo a gente pode trocar uma
ideia
aqui bem vamos paraa próxima pergunta D
Alan dose segura de K2 para prevenção de
problemas cardíacos e porque tê que ser
divididas em três
doses como eu devo fazer para o pedido
da farmácia porque Por que que tem que
ser três doses eu não tô entendendo essa
história de três
doses dos segura de K2 entre 100 a 300
mg por dia tá tudo totalmente seguro
agora dividir em três doses de onde é
que sai essa
informação não conheço essa
informação
é do Antônio Renato pergunta eu acho que
ele não tá ao vivo
bem uma possível razão para dividir a
dose em três seria manter a concentração
de K2 no sangue mas isso não faria muito
sentido porque K2 é uma vitamina
lipossolúvel
mas poderia ser justificado porque ela
tem uma meia vida curta no corpo né a
K2 Mas sinceramente eu não vejo uma
razão Grande para
fazer Teoricamente seria porque temha
vida curta e para manter a concentração
está no
organismo Mas eu não lembro de ter lido
um material uma fonte que exigia você
tomar isso três vezes ao dia como é uma
vitamina lipossolúvel eu acho que não
faria muito
sío mas a razão de utilizar ela para
saúde cardiovascular vocês acham que já
sabem né que ela vai direcionar o
cálcio para os ossos e dentes em vez de
ficar acumulando a parede das artérias
essa que a razão principal que você usa
K2 a K2 também tem um efeito anticâncer
tá e as os tipos de K2 você tem a
meninona que é a mk7 né que é menaka 7 e
tem mk4 que é a meninona 4 geralmente a
gente pede a mk7 porque ela tem a minha
vida mais
longa Mas sinceramente precisava ver a
fonte que você consultou para tá
orientando dividir em três doses porque
eu sinceramente eu não passo assim no
consultório eu passo dose diária única
eu acho que os paciente quanto menos
cois tiver que tomar várias vezes ao dia
mais é aderência porque é muito difícil
as pessoas lembrar de tomar várias vezes
ao dia as coisas geralmente lembra uma
semana depois para ah Ant Renato parece
que tá aqui eu falei em outra Live que
era para
tomar picado K2
eu falei que Live Antonio isso não tô
lembrar disso
não pode ser que você tenha entendido
errado sim mas se você me puder me
apontar qual foi essa Live que eu falei
isso eu vou dar uma checada lá de novo
tá mas acho que eu não falei isso não
não precisa eu geralmente eu não passo
assim não viu Antônio eu passo tomar uma
vez ao dia
só tá então prefiro a mk7 que é a
meninona 7 tá que ela tem minha vida
mais
longa próxima pergunta do
Carlos Caro Dr Alan para quem está em
ambiente estranho aprendendo duas
línguas simultaneamente e fazendo
pós-graduação e passou a sentir muito
enaque que se pode fazer nesses casos
então parece que o essa enxaqueca o
grande gatilho é o stresse né
lógico a gente aqui que é uma condição
complexa envolve vários fatores
neurofisiológicos tem fatores
comportamentais tem fatores
psicológicos então o próprio estress que
você tá tendo de mudança de ambiente ter
que aprender duas línguas ao mesmo tempo
já é stress suficiente né provavelmente
tá dormindo pouco né por conta da do
estudo tanto das línguas quanto da do
estudo da pós-graduação né do
mestrado tem os alimentos gatilho que
geralmente é queijo
vinho em alguns pacientes é leite outros
pacientes é o
glúten Tá mas queijo e vinho são também
bem comuns como
gatilhos faça até que gerenciamento do
stresse meditação
yoga procure fazer passeios em ambientes
assim bonitos assim com muita natureza
se você conseguir tiver tempo tenta ter
uma rotina de sono bem rigorosa né
dormir um sono de qualidade é muito
importante para melhorar essa
enxaqueca e além de você evitar queijo e
vinho tá corta o glutamato módico tá que
geralmente está em alimentos processados
tá em temperos processados tá esses
molhos aí que você compra pronto
geralmente tem glutamato que mais Aquele
agin moto que mais eh muitas vezes está
também
no no molho né o shoio né Tem glutamato
monossódico e o café também pode ser um
um um um gatilho Você tá tomando muito
café pode ser isso que tá gerando a
enxaqueca beber muita água vai prevenir
essas dores é muito importante você
beber bastante água desidratação é um
desencadeador tem vários suplementos que
podem ajudar com enzima q10 vitaminas do
complexo B especialmente a vitamina B2
tá a vitamina B2 b de bola 2 Ué por que
que não tá Ah desculpa não sei porque o
negócio subiu aqui a vitamina B2 b de
bola 2 é uma vitamina eh que tem um
efeito anti xaque acoso bem interessante
Então você tomar a vitamina B2 50 100
200 mg por dia ajuda na enxaqueca tá
junto com que 10 vai ser bem
interessante esse efeito tem também o
butterbur Né que é o Carrapicho né o
butterbur e é uma fitoterápico que tem e
feito anti chaqueo atividade física
moderada ajuda na
enxaqueca usar um óculos de proteção
contra a luz azul à noite vai ajudar
também se você passa muito tempo na
frente de telas isso vai filtrar luz
azul e vai ajudar na na enxaqueca a
cultura se você tiver acesso aí no país
onde você tá pode ajudar
bastante OK outra planta além do
butterbur que eu falei deixa eu escrever
aqui
no no bate-papo para vocês saberem que
que eu tô falando ó é porque o nome é
meio difícil
né é essa planta aqui Butter Bur tá ou a
erva de São João que é mais para
depressão Mas pode ajuda em xaque também
que é o hipérion Né Erva de São João Tom
tomar cuidado com essa planta que essa
aqui tem uma janela terapêutica Estreita
né porque o o essa planta aqui ela pode
dar problemas tá se usar dose muito
alta é o aloir colocou uma observação
interessante aqui
né observação interessante eu também tô
com essa insegurança viu
alui bem vamos pra
próxima
pergunta
eh Existe algum benefício em Tomar T3 e
T4 pela manhã junto com a vitamina C sim
a vitamina C eu falei isso Ah vocês não
vira porque eu falei isso foi numa
pergunta que foi feita no Instagram a
vitamina C tem estudos most que lá
melhora a absorção do hormônio
tiroidiano tá então a única coisa que
você pode estar tomando junto com o mono
tiroidiano em jejum é a vitamina
C tá tem esse estudo então que mostrou
se você associar a livo tiroxina o T4
esse Tudo foi feito com T4 não fori
feito com T3 vai aumentar a absorção do
hormônio se você tomar junto com a
vitamina
C e A vitamina C vai ter a ação antioxid
ID an vai ajudar no funcionamento da
tireoide ajuda na conversão t433
também ok acho que deu para responder já
essa né Deixa eu ver se eu esqueci algum
detalhe da pergunta Ué como que o
monitor apagou de repente aqui ah ligou
de novo
então tem benefício sim tá a vitamina C
vai ajudar na absorção do T4 já o T3 eu
não eu não conheço o estudo se fala mas
ele fala do T4 sim ele eleção T4 Dr Alan
Qual é a sua visão integrativa hoje
sobre a
vasectomia Existe alguma implicação
negativa tanto como possível
interferência na produção hormonal ou
outras possíveis complicações que não é
tão
divulgado na verdade
a vasectomia não baixa a testosterona Tá
mas eu não conheço estudo integrativo o
estudo que eu conheço é da Medicina
Ortodoxa Ok quem já fez intervenção
cirúrgica de correção de
varicocele pera aí mas varicocele é uma
coisa vasectomia é outra
né suspira cuidados acho que você quis
dizer transpira cuidados uma coisa assim
né
e cuidados do quê deixa eu ver quem fez
essa pergunta
é o
blanders Você tá aí blanders Você tá ao
vivo bem existia assim uma situação com
vasectomia que era raro mas que era bem
chato quando acontecia alguns pacientes
que fazem a vasectomia
isso é bem raro Mas acontece de ter uma
dor crônica que é muito difícil de
resolver sem reverter a vasectomia mas
na prática a gente não vê problemas
hormonais e e outros problemas quem faz
vasectomia não
tá Lógico que pode dar problema por
causa da cirurgia né Doro pós-operatória
hematoma infecção formação de granuloma
espermático é outra coisa o coto da do
vasinho que é cortado né o ducto
deferente pode formar granuloma nas
pontas e raramente que é muito raro um
para cada 25.000 casos pode ter
recanalização dos ductos deferentes e
uma falha na
esterilização agora a pergunta da
varicocele que eu achei que ficou meio
deslocada aqui no no meio
viu cuidados depois da correção você tá
falando de cuidados no pós-operatório
imediato ou cuidados em modo geral tipo
anos
depois não sei se eu entendi essa
pergunta se você tiver aí você me talvez
a gente troca uma ideia ao vivo
Tá qual a probabilidade do doutor fazer
um teste com a betal anina igual fez com
creatina eu Tom betal anina para
sabermos qual Está entregando a maior
quantidade real do
mesmo Como assim qual Está entregando a
maior quantidade real do qu porque a
Beta Alanina realmente estimula a
produção de
creatina é isso tá querendo
dizer eu não tô entendendo esse teste
você tá querendo que eu faça desculpa
Será que eu tô meio
você tá querendo dizer um teste
comparativo entre a Beta Alanina e a
creatina para determinar qual dos dois
tem mais benefícios É isso aí no caso é
a creatina que vai vai entregar mais viu
a creatina é um é um suplemento mais
estudado para isso a Bet lanina ela vai
aumentar a produção na verdade eu falei
errado para vocês a Bet lanina não vai
aumentar a produção de de creatina mas
de carnosina desculpe tá é de carnosina
é outro composto
proteico então a creatina aumenta a
creatina que é o depósito de energia pro
músculo utilizar na na atividade física
mas também tem um efeito positivo pro
cérebro e a betanina vai ajudar aumentar
a carnosina tá E essa carnosina vai
ajudar o quê a neutralizar o ácido
láctico
intracelular
Ok Isso reduz a fadiga muscular durante
os exercícios de alta intensidade Ok
então a betanina nesse caso é
menos estudado do que a a creatina e tem
menos benefício que a creatina Tá mas
para quem tem muita fadiga muscular
e não é o meu caso por
exemplo depois dos exercícios pode estar
usando então a balanina para aumentar
carnosina e atuar como um tamponamento
desse ácido né Desse ácido lático E
permitir que a pessoa Aguente mais
exercícios
Ok então de novo a balanina metac
carnosina que tô com um tampão
intracelular de ácido lático permite
mais tolerância menos fadiga nos
exercícios a creatina ela aumenta a
disponibilidade ATP certo porque ela
funciona como uma bateria né ela dá essa
energia pro músculo aumentando a energia
das contrações musculares
Ok mas eu de qualquer maneira eu tenho a
Bet lanina em casa mas assim escolher
entre os dois ou toma os dois ou se for
para escolher toma creatina creatina
mais evidência
tá
Eh pergunta agora a próxima para um
paciente com câncer de próstata uso de
finasterida para reduzir o PSA seria
benéfico nesse caso não existe uma
discussão de usar
finasterida para prevenir o câncer de
próstata mas não para tratar tá
bom a finasterida assim como a
dutasterida ela vai reduzir o tamanho da
próstata com uso prolongado né Se você
usar mais de 6 meses diminuir o PSA na
média pela metade tá isso geralmente é
utilizado na questão da prevenção
existia uma discussão antes se porque
teve um estudo há uns 10 anos atrás mais
ou menos que dizia o quê quem tava
usando a finast aterida Tava aparecendo
mais cânceres
Eh mais agressivos então na época ficou
na dúvida será que a finasterid tá
induzindo câncer agressivo ou se a
finasterid estava só diminuindo o
tamanho da próstata e tava facilitando a
biópsia da
Positivo então a conclusão final disso é
que não era finast ele não tava
aumentando o risco de câncer ou de
câncer de alto grau mas sim tava
ajudando a aumentar a eficiência da
biópsia tá
então voltando no que eu disse agora a
pouco só para fixar estudos anteriores
mostraram que a finasterida poderia
reduzir a incidência Geral de câncer de
próstata existi essas preocupações essas
dúvidas de que ela poderia aumentar o
risco de tumores de alto grau e
letalidade mas estudos mais recentes
mostraram e de longo prazo que a finida
não aumentaria o risco de morte por
câncer de próstata Ok só que eu não
gosto de finida pelo risco da síndrome
pós
finasterida que a pessoa fica sentio
fraca deprimida cai libido cai força
muscular tá então eh a literatura fala
que é raro Mas na minha prática não vejo
ser raro isso aí então pela literatura
seria 5% das pessoas que tem essa
síndrome no meu entendimento é mais 15 a
20% existe uma preocupação também que o
uso da Finasterida do tasa poderia
mascarar o PSA porque a gente sabe que
ele reduz pela metade
então geralmente o prescreve finasterida
T asida ele já faz a continha para cima
de considerar que esse PSA na verdade
estaria o dobro
Ok mas nunca deve considerar a
finasterida como um tratamento para
câncer de próstata não é o caso
Ok sempre colhi sangue com 8 A 9 horas
de jejum no máximo há poucos dias ouv Dr
Laí recomendando jejum de 12 para exame
de triglicerídeos Qual a explicação a
explicação é que esse exame muda demais
de acordo com o tempo que você tá de
jejum tá se você tiver um 3 horas de
jejum é um resultado se você tiver com
oito é outro com 12 é outro essa que é a
explicação tá Resumindo o caso
aí Lembrando que os trigueros são uma
forma de gord no sangue tá quando você
come qualquer alimento que tenha gordura
vai alterar significativamente os níveis
no sangue então por isso que muda muito
se é com 3 horas depois 8 horas depois
ou 12 horas
depois e geralmente a gente considera o
nível de jejum por isso que tá
recomendando 12
horas na verdade antes 2017 eh era
padrão você pedir um jejum de 12 horas
para quase todos os
exames porém estudos mais recentes
mostraram que para muitos casos um jejum
mais curto eh poderia não afetar a
maioria dos exames de
lipídeos Porém tem casos aí por exemplo
pessoas que T tendência a
hipert hipertrigliceridemia né ou seja
excesso de triglicérides no sangue
pessoal que tem mais de 400 de
triglicérides esse de 12 horas vai
ajudar a aumentar a precisão tá desse
exame Ficou claro isso daí Quem
perguntou isso
foi Marilda acho que ela não tá ao vivo
aqui ah Dr Alexandre Duarte em vídeo
afirma que mamão está cheio de frutose
cheio de antinutrientes cheio de toxinas
e como isso torna o intestino irritado
por isso que a pessoa defeca com
facilidade pois o intestino tem que
jogar tudo para fora faz sentido isso
olha o mamão ele tem fibras ele tem
vários nutrientes ele tem
luteína tem
astaxantina mas ele como qualquer
alimento ele ele tem
uma coisas boas e coisas ruins né
Eu acho que o mamão que as pessoas
gostam de comer que é uma mamão já
modificado ele é ele é doce demais não é
uma fruta que geralmente Eu recomendo
que as pessoas comam todos os dias tá
Mamão é uma
fruta particularmente problemática para
quem tem resistência sínica
bem mas no caso do mamão os
antinutrientes que tem nessa fruta não
são tão grandes não é inibidor de
tripsina Oxalato
Nitrato
fitato certo
e tem a questão da semente do mamão aque
é utilizado como remédio né para dengue
né olha nesse caso eu tendo não
concordar com várias coisas que ele
falou que é tem cheio de toxinas eu acho
que tá faltando evidência diso que ele
tá falando aí mas não é uma fruta que eu
realmente sou muito fã am mão
não Eu acho que outras frutas são
melhores é o caso do abacate é o caso
das frutas vermelhas é o caso do
Limão a banana que não tá muito madura
ainda tá eu não usaria o mamão como uma
fruta assim principal na aliment ação
mas comer tipo umas duas vezes por
semana não veria problema nenhum
tá a K2 e a k7 na verdade é a mesma
coisa aqui né a vitamina K2 mk7 tem que
ser juntas não aí tá Tá rolando uma
confusão aqui não são duas vitaminas não
tá é a mesma vitamina tá é a m eu falei
isso agora há pouco né a K2 tá mk4 a
meninona 4 e tem a mk7 meninona 7
OK são dois tipos de K2 Tá então não são
duas vitaminas diferentes não certo
então já falei da dose entre 100 a 300
microg por
dia
as que eu suplemento acho que é isso que
ele quis dizer aqui 150 MG de K2 da
vitamina
D não serve para prevenir de forma
geral deve deve tá junto né com a
vitamina D acho que tá querendo dizer
ou apenas Combate o cálcio Não Serve sim
para prevenir Por que que não
serviria não entendi essa tua colocação
só porque tá junto com a vitamina D não
serviria por que que não
serviria serve sim tá Serve sim você tá
aí né Antônio me explica que você tá
querendo dizer com
isso você tá aí né
bem eu eu vi que vocês estão fazendo
algumas perguntas aqui deixa
eu deixa eu deixa eu só antes de
continuar as perguntas deixa eu ver as
ao vivo
aqui uma observação do
aluir dizendo que tava com bastante
energia durante esse período
beleza fiz fiz
sim isso é Para Comparar as marcas
mesmo são as marcas que tem o selo
creapure tá de modo geral viu alui Tem
algumas marcas boas que não tem o selo
eh creapure mas na dúvida vai no Celo
creapure tá
eh eu tô usando da vitafor tá a marca de
Bet
lanina o que eu quis dizer aqui o
blandon tá aqui explicando sobre
varicocele junto da vasectomia tá são
duas situações diferentes mas aí você
operou os dois juntos é
isso ter algum problema digo quem já fez
correção não pode não poder ou ter
riscos pois já houve outra cirurgia no
local
que outra mas eu não
entendi a pessoa tinha varicocele operou
e depois foi operar vasectomia ou foi o
contrário ou operou os dois
juntos eu não tô entendendo ainda bland
você tá querendo dizer alguém que já
tinha ficel operou depois foi operar Vas
ecomia ou vice-versa ou operou as duas
juntas de nada Carlos por no meu
raciocínio K2 já está auxiliando a
vitamina D sim auxilia a vitamina D Sem
dúvida né seria auxilia sim eu tomo em
gejum T3 T4 Existe algum inconveniente
de tomar os dois juntos nenhum T3 T4 é
normal você tomar os dois
juntos então não consegue ajudar em
outras coisas além do cálcio não ajuda
na saú de cardiovascular de modo geral
você tá falando K2 Por que que não
consegue ajudar além de outras coisas
além do cálcio ajuda sim tem várias
ações na vitamina K2 tá bem vamos voltar
aqui pro
documento ã Qual que é a próxima
pergunta
aqui o valor máximo aceitável de
colesterol Total seria até 240 é por
volta disso em homens de 70 anos Isso se
aplica acho que para todos os homens tá
na verdade tem que avaliar esse
colesterol aqui de 240 pode ser bom ou
ruim vai depender do qu da
apolipoproteína b e da apolipoproteína
A1 tem que fazer relação entre os dois
tá e d uma olhada também na HDL
colesterol no LDL e nos triglicérides tá
E quais as causas se tiver ultrapassado
o valor limite
causas de colesterol alto tem
várias uma das causas é hipotiroidismo a
outra causa é falência de hormônios
sexuais tem causas genéticas
também tem causa de alimentação que tá
inadequada excesso de de consumo de
gorduras
trans excesso de alimentos processados
excesso de óleo vegetal de semente que
foi acrescido gordura
trans o próprio sedentarismo obesidade o
fumo consumo excessivo de
álcool são essas as causas tá tanto
deficiências hormonais quanto essas
outras que eu
falei já falei da causa genética
Deixa eu ver se eu respondi toda essa
pergunta
aqui já já respondi mas se quem que
perguntou Marilda posso desenvolver mais
o tema tá Marilda se
você
quiser a gente tem mais duas perguntas
aqui tem 500 mg de silimarina quantas
vezes ao dia e que hor
duas vezes ao dia geralmente
tá aí seria de manhã à noite ou de manhã
na hora do almoço tá
bom se puder se você lembrar de tomar
três vezes ao longo do dia também pode
tá se lembrar de tomar de 8 em 8 horas
também pode mas eu tomaria de 12 em 12
horas de manhã e à
noite
qual marca de óleo de
abacate Boa pergunta
essa Na verdade eu vou ficar te devendo
viu
Eh não tô lembrando agora de nenhuma
marca de de ó de abacate aqui na minha
cabeça aqui eu tô vendo umas marcas mas
eu acho que são marcas Americanas
wnf
bamia e paze né com Paz deixa eu ver se
essae essa paze tem no Brasil
Ah é brasileira eu vou vou passar o link
para vocês essa marca aqui é
boa Ué
cadê cadê o
link deu BO aqui no
link Será que tá fora do ar isso aqui
Deixa tentar de um outro jeito
Ah talvez seja esse Deixa eu olhar aqui
loja
paz.com.br mas não tá abrindo
não tentar essa wnf
aqui eu acho que o site deles tá fora do
ar
ah essa wnf também é brasileira
viu essa aqui essa aqui tá abrindo vou
mandar o link para vocês
aqui ó essa esse link aqui ó
Essa marca é
boa tem mais uma maca aqui deixa eu ver
se tem no
Brasil tem que ser um óleo de abacate
prensado a frio
né Deixa eu olhar aqui Bia
é eles têm óleos essenciais e óleos
vegetais passar para vocês esse link
aqui
também ó o link deles aqui ah mas esse
óleo é tão pequenininho
[Música]
mesu é enfim Ah tá mas mas isso aqui
eles vendem para uso tópico na pele não
é nem para fazer comida em casa
não esse aqui não é para comida para
fazer comida não é uma
aromaterapia essa empresa
aqui deixa eu ver se eu consigo achar
esse pase aqui pera aí que eu não
consegui achar
antes Aqui achei tem um outro site aqui
que tem Deixa eu mostrar para vocês aqui
esse aqui é o mais apropriado aqui
porque paraa cozinha
mesmo ah a loja agora entrou tava com
problema aí mas entrou agora
agora entrou a loja deles
aqui é porque os outros que eu vi aqui
esse também esse também que eu coloquei
o link aqui do wnf é mais para Pô na
pele tá então vou mostrar esse aqui que
deixa eu dividir uma outra tela aqui
deixa eu parar de deixa eu mostrar aqui
o
link aqui ó paz e
alimentos esse aqui
ó loap
com.br esse hord de abacate aqui é bom
Tá
beleza tá deixa eu trocar a tela de novo
aqui voltar aqui paraa guia
das
perguntas pronto
vamos
lá aliás esse jeito aqui é melhor né
fica maior um
pouco pretendo pedir K2 como prevenção o
que que o senhor
recomenda o que que eu recomendo tá meio
é usa K2 mk7 Eu já falei
né Antônio você aqui entrar aqui comigo
a gente manda um link a gente conversa
ao vivo aqui e e a gente tenta
esclarecer a tua dúvida melhor que que
você
acha você quer entrar ao vivo comigo eu
mando o link para você eu mando o link
aqui você entra que que você quer fazer
ol a dica aqui da Estela ó azeite
abacate está virgem da Paraíso Verde
está
virgem que quer dizer com está
virgem paraíso verja é o nome da loja
Estela ou é o nome da marca
a Beta Alanina que eu uso é da vitafor
tá deixa eu mostrar para você
aqui
vitafor Beta
[Música]
Alanina pronto e vou mostrar aqui para
você agora vou dividir a tela de novo
[Música]
Eh ó tá aí ó tá vendo esse que eu uso
Eita for
quer entrar comigo ou não Antônio Vocês
são muito envergonhados
viu vocês são muito envergonhados vocês
não querem entrar ao
vivo porque eu não tô acho não tô
entendendo direito você tá falando se
você entrasse ao vivo comigo eu consegui
ent entender melhor
tá acho que ele fugiu ficou com vergonha
tá
vendo agradeço não precisa cara é tudo é
tudo tímido todo mundo é tímido aqui ai
ai ai ai ai ai ai aí ó Paraíso Verde é a
marca Paraíso Verde a marca um amigo foi
eletrocutado com 13.000 v o braço foi
amputado mas todo o corpo está normal
inclusive os rins deu sorte então hein
ao receber alta do hospital você
recomenda um checkup geral
lógico Com
certeza por que que ele não continuou
com a pressão regulada já que tinha 100
nanog de D3 no
sangue não a vitamina D sozinha não
segura a pressão não Eliseu é um dos
fatores que a ajuda a regular a
hipertensão arterial mas não é assim que
a vitamina D é um antipertensivo potente
não tá dentro do hospital ele pegou uma
bactéria e passou a tomar antibiótico a
zonoterapia destrói todas as bactérias
rins ajuda ajuda tá eles mas não é santo
remédio assim não não é infalível Não
mas aí teria eh teria que tá fazendo um
ozônio numa dose mais alta a o risco
poderia aumentar um pouco mais
Ahã a energia elétrica entrou pela
barriga e saiu pelo braço esquerdo que
por sua vez foi amputada a energia
elétrica sempre lesa o membro por onde
sai se for nessa voltagem Sim sempre vai
lesar vende pelo mercado livre é
sensacional
bacana muito bom Paraíso Verde outra
dica aí tá fora que eu falei aqui né o
pase também tem esse produto aí para o
verde
Ok se a energia elétrica tivesse saído
pela cabeça a pessoa teria
morrido certamente
né Mas se a energia elétrica tivesse
saído pela perna é verdade que a pessoa
teria perdido a perna e também os órgãos
sexuais depende poderia sim perder
órgãos sexuais
sim ele diz que enquanto estava sendo
eletrocutado viu tudo branco para onde
olhar ele via branco por que que a
descarga elétrica fez ele ver tudo
branco não sei Eliseu sinceramente eu
não
sei supondo que D3 e Kefir sejam os mais
indicados para ele após sair do
hospital por que seriam os mais
indicados recomenda alguns suplementos
em especial para que essa pessoa que foi
eletrocutada e ficou tomando antibiótico
tem que ver os exames da pessoa certo
probiótico para ela seria uma boa né Por
causa do efeito colateral aí do
antibiótico certo mas por que que F
especificamente por causa do efeito
probiótico tudo bem vitamina D só se a
vitamina D você falou que a vitamina D
dele tava 100 Então não precisa de mais
de D3 né não precisa de mais de
D3 bem eu ia falar de dois artigos hoje
ainda mas eu acho que pelo correr do
tempo vamos deixar para semana que vem
esses artigos tá e semana que vem é
terça-feira normal tá pessoal
terça-feira
mesmo é só essa semana terça-feira não
pude fazer porque eu tava em Santo André
atendi até tarde e depois tive uma
reunião e acabei esquecendo
ontem qual tipo de ômega3 da vitafol
você recomenda é o rico em dha quer ver
vamos achar aqui
ó vamos achar aqui no site deles
não pera
aía ó esse
aqui esse Mega aqui ó que é o que tem
mais DH tá que tem 1500 de dha por
dose tá na verdade a dose não é uma
cápsula se eu não me engano são duas
deixa eu olhar aqui ó recomendação de
uso três são três cápsulas a que vai dar
1500 de
DH tá vendo esse aqui que eu acho que é
o
melhor tem 1500 de dha
Ok
ah mas ao ficar semanas no hospital o D3
dele diminuiu sim aí tem que medir de
novo né Eliseu supostamente diminuiu né
tem que medir
tá você fez um vídeo YouTube mostrando a
lista das creatinas mais puras e a
Master Wave ficou em primeiro não é não
é que eu decidi que a Master Way ficou
em primeiro foi do do estudo que saiu e
a gente divulgou naquele vídeo tá notei
que a masterway não tem o selo Então ela
é exceção porque na verdade essas marcas
foram submetidas a uma avaliação né do
em metro lá por isso que a gente tem
essa informação tem algumas marcas que
não tem o selo que não querem pagar o
royalty do seio tá do selo Desculpa só
que se você não conhece muito bem as
marcas é melhor ir pelo selo selo tá não
a a falta do selo não é motivo de
preocupação porque tem grandes marcas
que não tem o selo porque não querem
pagar o royalty pra empresa lá que dá o
sedo
tá
Hum e aí pessoal tem mais pergunta eu
não vou falar de artigo hoje não vou
deixar paraa semana que
vem
ah tá blandon respondeu não tinha visto
desculpa varic série primeiro há alguns
anos
ah
eh ter algum problema digo quem já fez
correção não pode
eh não não mas aí a varicocele o ponto
que opera a maioria das pessoas que
opera varicocele opera com incisão
subinguinal e a e a cirurgia de
vasectomia a incisão escrotal não vejo
problema não de fazer primeiro a
varicocele e depois fazer vasectomia não
vai aumentar o risco não tá não vejo
problema nesse ponto não viu blanders
Então posso utilizar da masterfit e a
Beta
lanina Master Way né você tá querendo
dizer creatina sim pode se você tá
falando da mesma coisa que o Eliseu tá
falando aqui sim
tá obrigado por tudo de nada Antônio de
nada bom final de semana para você
também sim você pode tomar as duas
juntas a creatina com a balanina Mas se
for para escolher uma escolha a creatina
tá porque tem mais evidência são coisas
diferentes Tá eu já expliquei porque a
balanina aumenta a carnosina que vai
atuar como tamponamento intracelular de
de ácido né ácido lático isso vai
permitir diminuir a diga já a creatina
vai aumentar a energia entre as duas a
creatina é mais importante
tá bem pessoal acho que deu
né acho que já deu
né bem obrigado por terem assistido essa
Live Me desculpe a confusão de ontem
ontem realmente não foi porque eu tava
muito ocupado eu estava muito ocupado na
terça ontem poderia ter feito a Live
tranquilamente mas eu me me Distraí com
outra coisa e acabei esquecendo tá e a
semana quem vem em volta pro horário
normal
das 19 horas na terça-feira tá bom
grande abraço um beijo coração de vocês
grande abraço e um beijo no coração de
vocês até semana que vem tchau
tchau Ainda bem que fez hoje porque você
prefere de de quarta-feira porque gente
fez uma aliás de quinta-feira a gente
fez uma votação e decidiu que o dia que
a maioria queria era Tera Foi por isso
viu aloir abraço para você também tchau
tchau pessoal